let's talk about the movie mom and dad
this is a very this is not the Hollywood
movie that you're always hearing about
you know sometimes they're just
recycling the same old plot this I gotta
say it's a very unusual plot it's about
moms and dads that are trying to kill
their kids yeah yeah yeah scared a
greater actress but since I'm on a stamp
I had a lot of confidence thank you yeah
I read a dark comedic you know take on
these there's something happens that is
outrageous it's like a plague a virus
it's a scary movie but it's a comedy
yeah and you know but it's great it's
very punk rock there is a deeper thing
you know like how you kind of lose your
soul if you're a parent that's totally
dedicated there are some moments of that
kind of grounding realness
like my life because they've given
everything up for my son yeah he doesn't
even know yeah postage stamp or in a
movie right parents are young children
right you seem like you're angry your
son right now and you just made a movie
about parents that attack the child it's
so I think I should call somebody right
now is what I'm saying totally I did not
bring any of my own life story to this
movie right don't worry right but they
were they were afraid I use a meat
tenderizer and they like him you chase
kids around with a meat tenderizer in
this film yeah because I'm a mom yeah
that's like your weapon like knife meat
tenderizer right feels good heft and
then you like go for it and they're
running right it's a lot of running a
lot of it and I have this meat
tenderizer after like you know not like
that hopefully and they they like took
it away from me who took it away from
you the set like the people because they
like crew that the supreme master he
took it away from you the director they
particularly when the cameras rolling
sometimes because they're afraid I was
like gonna kill if I wanted to kill
someone I would just go to the drugstore
buy a gun or something right
go to the drugstore and buy a gun a
drugstore in Texas yeah ice cream store
in Texas shooting LA so on the set
you're chasing your cousin buy a gun
yeah you're tracing kids with a meat
tenderizer and they got legitimately
scared cuz probably your said I am
Milwaukee like someone has some real
meat tenderizer someone flying in and
they give me this like foam doohickey
yeah you know and cuz they really are
afraid I'd kill a little auntie winter
yeah the winters name I think
[Applause]
you